This lecture is about the inverted
index construction.
In this lecture we will continue the
discussion of system implementation.
In particular, we're going to discuss
how to construct the inverted index.
The construction of the inverted index
is actually very easy if the data set
is very small, it's very easy to
construct dictionary and then store the
postings in a file.
The problem is that when our data is
not able to fit to the memory then we
have to use some special methods to
deal with it.
Unfortunately, in most retrieval
applications, that data set would be
large and they generally cannot be
loaded into memory at once.
There are many approaches to solve
the problem and sorting based method is
quite common.
It works in four steps as shown here.
First, you collect the local term ID,
document ID, and frequency tuples.
Basically you will not count the terms
in a small set of documents.
And then once you collect those
counts, you can sort those counts based on
terms so that you build a local
partial inverted index, and these are
called rounds. And then you write them
into a temporary file on the disk, and
then you merge in step three would do
pair-wise merging of these runs until
you eventually merge all the runs
to generate a single inverted index.
So this is an illustration of this
method.
On the left, you see some documents.
And on the right, we have shown
Term Lexicon
and DocumentID Lexicon.
These lexicons are to
map stream-based representations of
document IDs or terms into integer
representations or to
map back from integers to the stream
representation.
The reason why we are
interested in using integers to represent
these IDs is because integers are often
easier to handle.
For example, integers can be used as
index for array. They are also
easy to compress. So this is
one reason why we tend to map these
strings into integers.
So that well, so that we don't have to
carry these strings around.
So how does this approach work?
Well, it's very simple.
We're going to scan these documents
sequentially, and then parse the
document,
and count the frequencies of terms.
In this stage, we generally sort
the frequencies by document IDs
because we process each document
sequentially.
So we first encounter all the terms in
the first document.
Therefore, the document IDs are all 1s in
this case.
And this will be followed by
document IDs 2s.
They are naturally sorted in
this order
just because we process the data in the
sequential order at some point we will
run out of memory and then we would
have to write them into the disk.
But before we do that, we can sort
them just use whatever memory we have.
We can sort them and then
this time we're going to sort based on
term IDs.
Notice that here we're using the
term IDs
as a key to sort. So all the entries
that share the same term would be
grouped together.
In this case, we can see
IDs of documents that match the term
one will be grouped together.
And we're going to write this into the
disk as a temporary file, and that
would allow us to use the memory to
process
the next batch of documents.
And we're going to do that for all the
documents.
So we are going to write a lot of
temporary files into the disk.
And then the next stage is merge
sort. We are going to merge
them and sort them.
Eventually we will get a single
inverted index with their entries
are sorted based on term IDs.
And on the top we can see these are the
old entries for the documents that
match term ID1.
So this is basically how we can do
the construction of inverted index even
though the data cannot be
loaded into the memory.
Now we mentioned earlier that because
of postings are very large, it's
desirable to compress them.
So let's now talk a little bit about
how we compress inverted index.
The idea of compression in general is
to leverage skewed distributions of values,
and we generally have to use variable
length encoding instead of the fixed
length encoding as we use by default
in program languages like C++.
So how can we leverage the skewed
distributions of values to compress
these values?
In general, we would use fewer bits to
encode those frequently awards at the
cost of using longer bits to encode
those rare values.
So in our case, let's think about how
we can compress the TF (term frequency).
Now if you can picture what the
inverted index would look like, and you
see in postings, there are a lot of
term frequencies.
Those are the frequencies of terms in
all those documents.
Now,
if you think about what kind of
values are most frequent there, you
probably will be able to guess that
small numbers tend to occur far more
frequently than large numbers.
Why?
Think about the distribution of words
and this is due to the Zipf's law, and
many words occur rarely.
So we see a lot of small numbers.
Therefore we can use fewer bits for
the small but highly frequent
integers
at the cost of using more bits for
large integers.
This is a trade off, of course.
If the values are distributed uniformly,
this one will save us a lot of space.
But because we tend to see many small
values, they are very frequent.
We can save on average, even though
sometimes when we see a large number we
have to use a lot of bits.
What about the document IDs that we
also saw in postings?
They are not distributed in the
skewed way right.
So how can we deal with that?
Well, it turns out that you can use a
trick called d-gap and that is to
restore the difference of this term
IDs.
And we can imagine if a term has
matched many documents, then there
will be long list of document IDs.
So when we take the gap, I'm going to
take the difference between adjacent
the document IDs.
Those gaps will be small, so we will again
see a lot of small numbers.
Whereas if a term according only a few
documents, then the gap would be large.
The large numbers will not be frequent.
So this creates some skewed
distribution that would allow us to
compress these values.
And this is also possible because in
order to
uncover or uncompress these document
IDs.
We have to sequential process the data.
Because we store the difference and in
order to recover the exact the document
ID, we have to 1st recover the previous
document IDs and then we can add the
difference to the previous document ID
to restore the current document ID.
Now this was possible because we
only need to have sequential access to
those documents IDs.
Once we look up a term we fetch all the
document IDs that match the term.
Then we sequentially process them.
So it's very natural.
That's why this trick works.
And there are many different methods
for encoding. For example, the binary code
is a commonly used code in
programming languages where we use
basically fixed length encoding.
Unary code, Gamma code, and Delta code are
all possibilities and there are many
other possibilities. So let's look at
some of them in more detail.
Binary coding is really equal length
encoding, and that's our property for
randomly distributed values.
The unary coding is a variable length
encoding method.
In this case, an integer that's at least
one would be encoded as x-1, one
bits followed by zero.
So for example, three would be encoded
as two ones, followed by zero, whereas
five will be encoded as 4 ones,
followed by zero etc.
So now you can imagine how many bits do
we have to use for a large number like
100.
So how many bits do we have to use exactly
the full number like 100?
Exactly, we have to use 100 bits, right?
So it's the same number of bits as the
value of this number, so this is very
inefficient.
If you will likely see some large
numbers, imagine if you occasionally
see a number like 1000.
You have to use 1000 bits, so this only
works well if you are absolutely sure
that there will be no large numbers,
mostly very, very often using very
small numbers.
How do you decode this code?
Since these are variable length
encoding methods and you can't just
count how many bits, and then they just
stop. You can say 8 bits or 32 bits,
then you will start another code.
There are variable lengths, so you'll
have to rely on some mechanism. In this
case,
for unary you can see it's very easy to
see the boundary.
Now you can easily see zero with
signal, the end of encoding.
So you just count how many ones you
have seen and until you hit zero you
have finished one number.
You will start another number.
Now we just saw that the unary coding
is too aggressive in rewarding small
numbers.
If you occasionally, you can see a very
big number.
It would be a disaster.
So what about some other, less
aggressive method?
Well, Gamma coding is one of them.
And in this method we are going to use unary
coding for a transformed form of the
value, so it's one plus the floor of the
log of X.
So the magnitude of this value is much
lower than the original X.
So that's why we can afford
using unary code for that.
So we will first have the Unary
code for this log of X.
This will be followed by a uniform code
or binary code, and this is basically
the same uniform code and binary code
are the same, and we're going to use
this code to code the remaining part of
the value of X.
And this is basically precise X - 1
to the floor of the log of X.
So the unary code basically coded the
floor of log of X, add one there.
But the remaining part will be
using uniform code to actually code the
difference between the X and this
two to the log of X.
And it's easy to show that for this
value this difference, we only need to
use up to this many bits and floor of
log of X bits.
This is easy to understand, if the
difference is too large then we would
have a higher floor of log of X.
So here are some examples.
For example, 3 is encoded as
101.
The first 2 digits are the unary code,
right.
So this is for the value 2.
10 encodes 2 in unary coding.
And so that means log of X, the floor of
log of X is 1 because we want actually
use unary code to encode one plus the
floor of log of X.
Since this is 2, then we know that the
floor of log of X is actually one.
But three is still larger than two
to the one, so the difference is 1, and
then one is encoded here at the end.
So that's why we have 101 for 3.
Similarly, 5 is encoded as 110
followed by 01
and in this case, the unary code
encodes 3.
And so this is the unary code 110.
And so the floor of log of X is 2.
And that means we are going to compute the
difference between 5 and 2 to the
two, and that's one, and so we now have
again one at the end.
But this time we're going to use 2
bits, cause with this level floor of log
of X we could have more numbers 5, 6, 7
they would all share the same prefix
here,110.
So in order to differentiate them we
have to use 2 bits in the end to
differentiate them.
So you can imagine six would be 10
here in the end instead of 01 after
110.
It's also true that the form of gamma
code is always:
first odd number of bits and in the
center in there is a zero.
That's the end of the unary code.
And before that, on the left side
of this zero, there will be all ones an
on the right side of this zero, it's
binary coding or uniform coding.
So how can you decode such a code?
You again first do unary coding right
Once you hit zero, you have got the
unary code.
And this also would tell you how many
bits you have to read further to decode
the uniform code.
So this is how you can decode Gamma code.
There was also the error code that's
basically the same as gamma code, except
that you replace the unary prefix with
the gamma code, so that's even less
conservative than gamma code in terms
of rewarding the small integers.
So that means it's OK if you
occasionally see a large number.
It's OK with delta code.
It's also fine with gamma code, it's
really
a big loss for Unary code and they are all
operating of course at different
degrees of favoring small
integers.
And that also means.
They would be appropriate for a certain
distribution, but none of them is
perfect for all distributions.
Which method works the best with
have to depend on the actual
distribution in your data set.
For inverted index compression, people
have found that gamma coding seems to
work well.
So how do I uncompressed invert index
when we just talked about this first,
you decode those encode integers and we
just I think discussed how we decode
unary coding and gamma coding.
So I won't repeat.
And what about the document IDs that
might be compressed using d-gap. We're
going to do sequential decoding.
So suppose the encoded ID list is x1,
x2, x3, etc.
We first decode x1 to obtain the
first document ID ID1.
Then we would decode x2, which is
actually the difference between the
second ID and the first one.
So we have to add the decoder value of
x2 to ID1 to recover the value
of the
ID at this second position, right.
So this is where you can see the
advantage of converting document IDs
into integers, and that allows us to do
this kind of compression and we just
repeat until we decode all the
documents every time we use the
document ID in the previous position to
help you recover the document ID in the
next position.